wasn't there a story wasn't there a part
that was edited out or something
that winston was supposed to have then
then didn't happen yeah
in the very beginning and i've been
writing we have different um
recollections because we
and everyone said i don't say ivan i'm
sorry man but uh i don't remember it
like that i'm not saying you're wrong
we're both old men so maybe one of our
memories is a little short here but
maybe it's mine i don't know but um in
the beginning
there was a backstory winston came in in
the very beginning you know when they
first leave the university remember they
get kicked out of university
and he comes in and um and he's an
ex-air force
colonel who was a demolitions expert and
he kind of ran the ghostbusters and so
um and then just before we started
shooting
they wrote him out i mean basically
instead of coming in on page eight he
came in on page 68
and uh and all the backstory where i
come in and we talk about who i am and
i'm auditioning and i'm explaining what
i do
he just says um you know uh there's a
steady paycheck cannot believe anything
you say
and um and i thought that's just a funny
line
but you don't get to know who this guy
is you know you just
you know it's it's a funny bit but
unfortunately it doesn't give you a lot
to play
so you so as an actor you have to bring
all of that
with you and hopefully people will see
it
you know your mailman comes up you don't
want to you don't know everything about
him but you can see
in him who he is yes and so
i i think the studio probably uh
worked overtime to try and make sure
that the ghostbusters were
always thought of as three guys
and i think it's the fans and i really
appreciate the mans who really
embrace the character um
and at one point winston was uh one of
the
best-selling dolls they had and they
were surprised
but i think that's um that's because the
fans really
love the character